government advisers predict 20,000
people will die with coronavirus in the
UK even with the social distancing and
shielding of vulnerable groups analysis
of the first 386 deaths in the UK has
shown that 98 percent had underlying
health conditions the majority were
elderly with the oldest being 105 well
we don't know for sure was how many died
because of the virus every year 600,000
people in the UK died that's one
thousand six hundred and forty four
deaths every day and most of those would
be elderly or in poor health so there's
an overlap between the background
mortality and those dying during the
epidemic so let's take those 20,000
predicted deaths from coronavirus now
one of the government's key advisors
hazard of the guest this week that
between half and two-thirds of those
dying would probably have done so soon
anyway so do the math and deduct those
from the predicted death and you're left
with somewhere between six thousand six
hundred and sixty-seven
and ten thousand deaths that can be
attributed directly to the virus
statisticians call those excess deaths
and by way of comparison regular
seasonal flu causes 8,000 excess deaths
a year
so not dissimilar there's no doubt that
social distancing will save many lives
but the economic shutdown also has a
human cost the financial crash of 2008
resulted in unemployment increasing to
212 million across the world the
resulting poverty and poor health caused
Ana decimated 260,000 additional cancer
deaths and 10,000 additional suicides
now every death is of course a tragedy
and right now we're staying at home to
prevent the NHS from being catastrophic
aliy overwhelmed by the virus
but once we're over the peak in cases
begin to fall the government will have
to balance the lives saved through
social distancing with the lives lost by
prolonging the economic pain